est ce que tout ceci n'est pas dérisoire
j'ai créé un monstre
maintenant je dois vivre avec
div bientôt sera le seul à rayonner
je ne vois pas quel point la rue est
devenue l'aide monstrueusement l'aide
tu peux te plaindre mais tu avis la
planète moins cher
ya la planète survie de l'appuyer
autrement maintenant ce n'est pas son
nom qu'il faut vendre c'est lui je me
sens très différentes yves saint laurent
défiez approche de rien comme ça
travaille
avec deux bassins de marche
nice alors
l'espagnol est secrète des fois je ferme
les yeux
et s'ouvre je ne vois que des choses
lourdes ici
cannes
et réalité
y arrivera
je pense que nous obtenons aujourd'hui
j'étais plus de concurrence c'est bien
moindre